[Music]
for the second year in a row were taking
our show down to San Diego for calm
[Applause]
we're gonna be airing a week of shows
live from the Spreckels Theatre in San
Diego I'm gonna be sitting down with the
cast of Silicon Valley Game of Thrones
and suicides fly
[Applause]
it's all happening Wednesday July 20th
through Sunday July 24th dates a little
different different schedule yeah
Wednesday through Sunday if you want to
get more information visit team koco.com
slash ladies and gentlemen to help us
get into the mood for comic-con
let's do something special let's bring
out Captain Kirk's arch-nemesis
he's a genetically enhanced super being
who has vowed to conquer the earth he's
also a hard-working club comic he'd seen
him all around the country he always
gets the laughs please welcome Comic Con
[Music]
yes yes it's great to be back
set your phasers to giggle we're going
to have some fun I know what you're
thinking Khan has put on some weight yes
true
I used to control my own planet and now
I can't even control my own appetite
I used to hunger for revenge now i
hunger for girls junior i used to be
full of rage now I'm just full of
McNuggets
I'm telling you folks I eat too much
so anyway I'm single dating dating stuff
it is tough yes my favorite dating app
is a GrubHub I eat too much check this
out
what you call 20 captain kirk's at the
bottom of the ocean you call it a lot of
squid getting boned that guy will screw
anything yes even squid yes Captain Kirk
is a horndog all right yes but did you
know that he's also a corn dog that's
right
he pork the Gorn Google it's Google it's
my tricky friends yes that Kirk he's
overcompensating for something Captain's
Log
more like captain's tweek
[Music]
the only place in the universe that he
has not discovered is the g-spot now
don't get me wrong that spark he was
into some freaky stuff too
he was a real freak there's a reason he
used to walk around like this it's got
the Vulcans shocker two in the pink two
in the stink and a big thumbs up you can
bridge
[Applause]
let's vomit corn everybody we're back
[Applause]
you